picture this you wake up one morning and
you feel a little bit sick no particular
symptoms just not 100% and so you go to
the doctor and she also doesn't know
what's going on with you so she suggests
they run a battery of tests and after a
week goes by the results come back
turns out you tested positive for a very
rare disease that affects about 0.1% of
the population and it's a nasty disease
horrible consequences you don't want it
so you ask the doctor
you know how certain is it that I have
this disease and she says well the test
will correctly identify 99% of people
that had the disease and only
incorrectly identify one percent of
people who don't have the disease so
that sounds pretty bad I mean what are
the chances that you actually have this
disease I think most people would say
99% because that's the accuracy of the
test but that is not actually correct
you need Bayes theorem to get some
perspective
[Music]
Bayes theorem can give you the
probability that some hypothesis say
that you actually have the disease is
true given an event that you tested
positive for the disease to calculate
this you need to take the prior
probability the hypothesis was true that
is how likely you thought it was that
you have this disease before you got the
test results and multiply it by the
probability of the event given the
hypothesis is true that is the
probability that you would test positive
if you had the disease and then divide
that by the total probability of the
event occurring that is testing positive
this term is a combination of your
probability of having the disease and
correctly testing positive plus your
probability of not having the disease
and being falsely identified the prior
probability that a hypothesis is true is
often the hardest part of this equation
to figure out and sometimes it's no
better than a guess but in this case a
reasonable starting point is the
frequency of the disease in the
population so 0.1% and if you plug in
the rest of the numbers you find that
you have a nine percent chance of
actually having the disease after
testing positive which is incredibly low
if you think about it now this isn't
some sort of crazy magic it's actually
common sense applied to mathematics just
think about a sample size of a thousand
people now one person out of that
thousand is likely to actually have the
disease and the test would likely
identify them correctly as having the
disease but out of the 999 other people
one percent or ten people would falsely
be identified as having the disease so
if you're one of those people who has a
positive test result and everyone's just
selected at random well you're actually
part of a group of eleven where only one
person has the disease so your chances
of actually having it are one in eleven
nine percent it just makes sense when
Bayes first came up with this theorem he
didn't actually think it was
revolutionary he didn't even think it
was worthy of publication he didn't
submit it to the Royal Society of which
he was a member and in fact it was
discovered in his papers after he died
and he had abandoned it for more than a
decade his relatives asked his friend
Richard price to dig through his papers
and see if there was anything worth
publishing in there and that's where
price discovered what we now know as
the origins of Bayes theorem Bayes
originally considered a thought
experiment where he was sitting with his
back to a perfectly flat perfectly
square table and then he would ask an
assistant to throw a ball onto the table
now this ball could obviously land and
end up anywhere on the table and he
wanted to figure out where it was so
when he'd asked his assistant to do was
throw on another ball and then tell him
if it landed to the left or to the right
or in front behind of the first ball and
he would note that down and then ask for
more and more balls to be thrown on the
table what he realized was that through
this method he could keep updating his
idea of where the first ball was now of
course he would never be completely
certain but with each new piece of
evidence he would get more and more
accurate and that's how Bayes saw the
world it wasn't that he thought the
world was not determined that reality
didn't quite exist but it was that we
couldn't know it perfectly and all we
could hope to do was update our
understanding as more and more evidence
became available when Richard Price
introduced Bayes theorem
he made an analogy to a man coming out
of a cave maybe he'd lived his whole
life in there and he saw the Sun Rise
for the first time and kind of thought
to himself is is this a one-off is this
a quirk or does the Sun always do this
and then every day after that as the Sun
rose again he could get a little bit
more confident that well that was the
way the world works so Bayes theorem
wasn't really a formula intended to be
used just once it was intended to be
used multiple times each time gaining
new evidence and updating your
probability that something is true so if
we go back to the first example when you
tested positive for a disease what would
happen if you went to another doctor get
a second opinion and get that test run
again but let's say by a different lab
just to be sure that those tests are
independent and let's say that test also
comes back as positive now what is the
probability that you actually have the
disease well you can use Bayes formula
again except this time for your prior
probability that you have the disease
you have to put in the posterior
or probability the probability that we
worked out before which is 9% because
you've already had one positive test if
you crunch those numbers the new
probability based on two positive tests
is 91% there's a 91% chance that you
actually have the disease which kind of
makes sense to positive results by
different labs are unlikely to just be
chance but you'll notice that
probability is still not as high as the
accuracy the reported accuracy of the
test Bayes theorem has found a number of
practical applications including notably
filtering your spam you know traditional
spam filters actually do a kind of bad
job there's too many false positives too
much of your email ends up in spam but
using a Bayesian filter you can look at
the various words that appear in emails
and use Bayes theorem to give a
probability that the email is spam given
that those words appear now Bayes
theorem tells us how to update our
beliefs in light of new evidence but it
can't tell us how to set our prior
beliefs and so it's possible for some
people to hold that certain things are
true with a hundred percent certainty
and other people to hold those same
things are true with zero percent
certainty what base theorem shows us is
that in those cases there is absolutely
no evidence nothing anyone could do to
change their minds and so as Nate silver
points out in his book the signal and
the noise we should probably not have
debates between people with a hundred
percent prior certainty and zero percent
prior certainty because well really
they'll never convince each other of
anything most of the time when people
talk about Bayes theorem they discuss
how counterintuitive it is and how we
don't really have an inbuilt sense of it
but recently my concern has been the
opposite that maybe we're too good at
internalizing the thinking behind Bayes
theorem and the reason I'm worried about
that is because I think in life we can
get used to particular circumstances we
can get used to results maybe getting
rejected or failing at something or
getting paid a low wage and we can
internalize that as though we are that
man emerging from the cave and we see
the Sun Rise every day and every
and we keep updating our beliefs to a
point of near certainty that we think
that that is basically the way that
nature is it's the way the world is and
there's nothing that we can do to change
it
you know there's Nelson Mandela's quote
that everything is impossible until it's
done and I think that is kind of a very
Bayesian viewpoint on the world if you
have no instances of something happening
then what is your prior for that event
it will seem completely impossible your
prior maybe zero until it actually
happens you know the thing we forget in
Bayes theorem is that our actions play a
role in determining outcomes and
determining how true things actually are
but if we internalize that something is
true and maybe we're a hundred percent
sure that it's true and there's nothing
we can do to change it well then we're
going to keep on doing the same thing
and we're going to keep on getting the
same result it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy so I think a really good
understanding of Bayes theorem implies
that experimentation is essential if
you've been doing the same thing for a
long time and getting the same result
that you're not necessarily happy with
maybe it's time to change so is there
something like that that you've been
thinking about if so let me know in the
comments
[Music]
hey this episode of veritasium was
supported in part by viewers like you on
patreon and by audible audible is a
leading provider of spoken audio
information including an unmatched
selection of audio books original
programming news comedy and more so if
you think about trying something new and
you haven't tried the audible yet you
should give them a shot and for viewers
of this channel they offer a free 30-day
trial just by going to
audible.com/veritasium you know the book
I've been listening to an audible
recently is called
the theory that would not die by Cheryl
birch McGrane and it is an incredible
in-depth look at Bayes theorem and I've
learned a lot just listen to this book
including the crazy fact that Bayes
never came up with the mathematical
formulation of his rule that was done
independently by the mathematician
pierre-simon Laplace so really I think
he deserves a lot of a credit for this
theory but Bayes gets naming rights
because he was first and if you want you
can download this book and listen to it
as I have when I've just been driving in
the car or going to the gym which I'm
doing again and so if there's a part of
your day that you feel is kind of boring
then I can highly recommend trying out
audiobooks from audible just go to
audible.com slash Barrett's hassium so
as always I want to thank audible for
supporting me and I want to thank you
for watching